يمتد قطاع غزه على مساحه 360 كيلومترا
مربعا بطول نحو واحد واربعين كيلو مترا
تحيط به من الشمال والشرق مستوطنات
اسرائيليه باتت تسمى اصطلاحا مستوطنات
غلاف غزه يبلغ عددها نحو 50 مستوطنه وتقع
ضمن مسافه نحو 20 كيلومترا
يقطنها بحسب احصائيات اسرائيليه لعام 2019
خرابه 55 الف مستوطن تتكون مستوطنات
الغلاف من ثلاثه مجال سائق اقليميه تتبع
الحكومه الاسرائيليه وهي مجلس اشكول ويمتد
على مساحه
380 كلم مربعا ويسكنه اكثر من 13 الف
مستوطن يعيشون في اثنتين وثلاثين مستوطنه
مجلس شاعر ويمتد على مساحه 180 كيلومترا
مربعا وفيه احدى عشره مستوطنه يعيش فيها
اكثر من سبعه الاف مستوطن ابرزها ستيروت
مجلس اشكل او مدينه عسقلان الفلسطينيه
ويقع على مساحه
175 كيلومترا مربعا ويعيش فيه حوالي 17
الف مستوطن ضمن 40 مستوطنات
ويتكون الغلاف من مستوطنات وبلدات ابرزها
مستوطنات كيسوفيم زيكين نحل عوز كريات
ملاخي وكريات جات وكرم ابو سالم اضافه الى
مدن ديمونا وعسقلان
ديموغرافيا يشكل اليهود الشرقيون اغلبيه
سكان هذه المستوطنات ويعتبرون ايديولوجيا
من متبعي اليمين الديني المتطرف ومعظمهم
من غادروا مستوطنات قطاع غزه عند الانسحاب
الاسرائيلي عام 2005
تمثل زراعه النشاط الاقتصادي الاهم
لمستوطني غلاف غزه
وتقدم الحكومه الاسرائيليه لهم تسهيلات من
قبيل تخفيض اسعار استئجار الاراضي المخصصه
لاقامه مشاريع زراعيه او استثماريه
تعتبر هذه المستوطنات حاجزا جغرافيا
وديموغرافيا يمكنه ان يمنع مستقبلا قيام
دوله فلسطينيه متصله
[موسيقى]